oh snap it looks like Iron Man will be
chasing a little golden man after all
just a month after Disney bosses felt
the wrath of Iron Man fans for not
including actor Robert Downey jr. as
part of the Avengers endgame Oscars
campaign the mouse House has officially
changed course Disney which owns Marvel
Studios has now updated end games for
your consideration page to include
Downey Jr's name in the Best Supporting
Actor category but that's not all the
Iron Man actor is actually joined in
that category by a veritable who's who
of Marvel Cinematic Universe stalwarts
including Chris Evans Mark Ruffalo Chris
Hemsworth Jeremy Renner Don Cheadle Josh
Brolin and Paul Rudd on the actor side
Disney is also now pushing Scarlett
Johansson Gwyneth Paltrow Zoe Saldana
Karen Gillan and brie Larson in the Best
Supporting Actress race that's so many
actors it kind of makes you feel bad for
the people who got left out this news
comes after what's been a surprisingly
tumultuous month for Disney with regards
to Avengers end games Academy Awards
campaign MCU fans reacted with shock
that the company had initially chosen
not to push robert downey jr who many
believed was more than deserving of an
oscars nomination or any of the end game
cast than the chase burr award season
glory the decision was even more
surprising given that Disney's original
for your consideration announcement for
end game included planned campaigns for
Best Picture and Best Director
not to mention virtually every technical
category it now appears that Disney
brass may have simply been figuring out
the logistics of which actors to slot
into what category for Downey jr. and
his MCU teammates fittingly RDJ will now
stand alongside his fellow Avengers as
they attempt to charge the Oscars and
net the MCU its first acting statue
though an Oscar win is far from
guaranteed for any of the Avengers end
game cast Downey jr. in particular seems
to have the odds in his favor
after all Downey jr. is seen by most
Marvel fans as the founding father of
Disney and Marvel superhero franchise
machine with 2008 iron man marking the
film that blasted the MCU into action
the year sense of scene RDJ appear as
the brash but brilliant billionaire Tony
Stark in 9 more Marvel films including
his uncredited cameo in the Incredible
Hulk and that continued presence
essentially made Downey jr. the face of
the MCU over its first three phases
told you so general but that super
soldier program was put on ice for a
reason I've always felt that hardware
was much more viable with the actors
time in the MCU officially at an end
after his tearful Avengers endgame
goodbye any awards season love for
Downey jr. would be the culmination of
over a decade's worth of work and
happening what is more often than not
been the MCS most complex character but
while Iron Man fans will almost
certainly be over the moon that Downey
jr. may have a chance to take a bow with
a golden statue in his hand on
Hollywood's biggest night the man
himself may not be quite as excited at
this unexpected turn of events after the
initial no Oscar campaign for our DJ's
Iron Man news broke the actor used an
appearance on the Howard Stern Show to
address the supposed snub telling the
world that it wasn't really into an
Oscar campaign for his work in Avengers
end game to begin with he explained to
stern there was some talk about it and I
said let's not like it or not
Downey Jr's iron hat has officially been
tossed into the award season ring for
what certain to be an intriguing
Supporting Actor battle but even if it
remains unlikely in the grand scheme
that our DJ will take home a statue at
the 2020 Oscars the idea that his iconic
work is the MC who's top dog hasn't
earned him a spot in the conversation
until now is pretty absurd all that
being said if there's a second to
vengers endgame actor worthy of
generating serious Oscars buzz it's
Chris Hemsworth after toiling away in a
pair of underwhelming Thor movies the
god of thunder finally found his mojo
and take a white tt's thor ragnarok but
nothing we'd seen of Hemsworth Thor
could have prepared us for the actors
heart-wrenching work in endgame
[Music]
while our DJ's tearful farewell proved
to crowning achievement to the MCU
watching Hemsworth spat Thor worked
through the emotional carnage of his
once privileged life was often the most
intriguing elements of endgame so yeah
if the Academy is preparing to show
Downey jr. some love it'd be nice to see
Hemsworth sharing in that adoration for
now we should probably just be happy
that Robert Downey jr. is officially
part of the award season chatter here's
hoping the Academy loves him 3,000 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]